[Captioned by Judy V. at Y Translator]
Guys, today we are outside
in the great big wilderness
because we're going to be testing
out ten different life hacks
designed for camping.
These are all things
that I've seen online
that seem like they could be really cool, and I want to put them to the test
to see how well they actually work.
The first life hack were going to
be testing out is using plastic
drinking straws to make yourself
single-serve containers of spices.
To start off, we'll take a pair of pliers
or a multi-tool, and pinch one end
of the straw really near the end.
Using a lighter,
melt the end of the straw,
and it should seal shut.
Once you have one end
of the straw sealed,
decide how much spice you want in it,
and cut the straw there.
Now, just take the straw
and kind of push it down into the spice,
until it's as full as you want it to be.
Be sure to leave enough space at the top
that you're able to pinch
the top of the straw without it
binding into the spices.
Now, just like when we started,
use your lighter to seal it off.
At this point, we have
a waterproof container
that might even be airtight
full of the spices our choice.
When we're ready to use it,
we can just cut it open
and pour it over our food.
I would say that this definitely
does work pretty well.
I'm doing it while I'm already
out here in the wilderness,
where as this is really something
you want to do at home
to prepare to go camping.
If you're already out here,
and you have the spices,
then of course, you don't need
to put them in smaller containers.
They're already in--
You already got them.
You don't need to bring them out with you.
But this does definitely work.
I'm going to be using this in the future.
Our next camping hack is supposed
to help you carry firewood
as you're walking around,
trying to gather it all up.
It involves taking two sticks,
and tying two or three lengths
of paracord in between them,
to then form a sort of carrier that
you can put the rest of the wood in.
Now, I don't anticipate this
working any better or worse
because I have a neon rainbow piece
of paracord, but I guess it's possible.
I'm good at knots.
Got a bunch of pieces of firewood.
I tried to make sure that
they're all long enough,
that they span from
one string to the other.
Let's give this thing a shot.
That was pretty neat
and that's probably more
than I can easily gather up in my arms.
So this is works pretty slick.
Next up, we're going to test a hack
that lets you have a bar of
soap near your washing station,
and fit it into the foot
on a pair of nylons
and you're then able to lather
up right through the material
without having to take the bar of soap,
and then set it down on
something dirty or grungy.
That's uh, that's stretchy.
Now, we'll hang this from our table next
to a jug of water and we should be
able to use it to wash your hands.
With soap and a nylon,
might look a little bit strange
but it works pretty well.
I'm able to lather up my hands
right through the cloth,
and then I don't have to set
the soap down on the ground
or anything covered in dirt.
Our next camping hack teaches us
a way that we can dry off our shoes
if we've unfortunately stepped
in a stream or something like that
by letting them sit overnight
with a t-shirt filling the shoe,
and in theory, by morning,
it should be dry.
So this one we're going to let go
overnight and see how it works.
Of course if it gets completely dry,
it's going to depend on the temperature
and the humidity and everything
else going on around you, but
we should be able to see at least
if one is more dry than the other.
The next test is for a camping hack
that's been floating around the internet
for about as long as I can remember.
The idea is that you
can take a headlamp,
strap it to the side of a jug of water,
and it will provide a lantern
that will just beautifully
light everything up .
We're going to try that out.
So there's our headlamp
attached to the jug of water,
and it's putting off light kind of all around,
which is what we were hoping for.
The question is whether
this is actually worth doing.
Here's how much it's going right now.
It does provide some light, maybe if
you were playing cards on this table,
it would be enough to play by,
But if we take the headlamp off,
I would say we actually have quite a bit
more light just using the light bulb itself.
So here's my thought.
If you have a headlamp instead of taking
it off and strapping it on to the milk jug,
just wear it on your head and you
can see everything you need to.
I don't think this life hack is worth it.
Next up is had to take an aluminum can
a tea light to make a lantern
that's supposed to light up a large area.
We'll start by cutting a slit
from near the bottom of the can
to near the top and then moving
sideways kind of cutting
a big letter "I" into our can.
Well, then take the two sides, and fold
them open, and place the tea light inside.
We can now see a side-by-side
comparison of a candle in our little can
and a candle that's
just sitting on the table.
I'm not sure if there's a lot more light
coming out of the one on the can
but there are a couple
advantages I can see.
The light is a little bit more directed
and if you're trying to do something specific
that might be really helpful,
but I would say the best use
is that this candle is flickering a lot
and when there's any gust of wind it
almost gets put out
and if there's any strong wind it
would go out, so the can really does
a good job of shielding the candle
from being blown out by a slight breeze.
I don't think it's gonna make a huge
difference in terms of how much
brightness is getting put off,
but at least it protects it from the wind,
and I'd say that's an
advantage worth knowing.
Our next campaign hack is one
that intrigued me quite a bit.
It involves using a hollowed-out
half of an orange and some vegetable oil
to make an oil lamp
candle kind of thing,
and why you are camping and
have an orange and some oil
but not say a lantern or
just a normal candle,
I'm not sure, but I still
really want to try this out.
Our orange is cut in half,
and the goal is to remove all of the fruit
but leave this fibrous center stem portion.
That's actually what we're
going to try and use as the wick.
All right. We've got our orange
pretty much cleared out now.
We've still got the center fiber stem bit.
So now we need to try filling
the orange with some vegetable oil.
The lifehack didn't specify
if there's a good way to keep
your orange from tipping over.
Well, so far, I'm definitely having
a bit of trouble getting that to light.
Maybe it's still too full of orange
juice need to dry it off more.
We had to dry out the wick and then
it took I'd say at least two
minutes of concentrated lighter
fire to really get that to catch.
So you've got that, you might
have all of your light covered.
But it does seem to be burning now.
Not very strong.
I think a good sneeze would put it out.
Now, we're going to test a method
of making some campfire popcorn
using popcorn, oil,
aluminum foil and a stick.
The idea is that we'll pour some
popcorn and some oil into the foil,
hold it over into sort of a pouch,
and then we'll use two of the corners
to reach up and connect onto our stick,
and then we'll be able to put
that whole contraption into the fire
over some coals and we should be
able to get some popcorn
popping inside the pouch.
Probably still not going to be
anywhere near all the way popped.
Lookie at that.
There are still some unpopped
kernels and the ones that stayed
near the bottom did get fairly singed,
but I would say that's more of an issue
of my technique than anything else.
I think with a little bit more practice.
I could make this work out pretty nicely.
So we've got the one shoe that
had the T-shirt stuff down into it,
and we have one shoe that
did not have anything in it,
just trying feel a difference between them.
It's actually been sitting
out here in a fair bit
of sunshine for a couple hours now.
As it was, both of
the shoes were mostly dry.
But the shoe without the t-shirt in it
was definitely a little bit more wet
down along the seams,
Both of the upper portions of
the shoe were just the same,
they both felt dry inside and out.
But the one without the shirt
definitely had more water,
you know, pooling down in these areas
where there isn't as much circulation.
I think the T-shirt really did do a good
job of helping absorb that portion
of the water because
the shoe with the t-shirt in it
felt more uniformly dry, even though
both of them were doing pretty well.
The next camping hack we want to test
once again involves half of an orange,
and it's to see if we can cook a
cinnamon roll inside the orange peel
in the coals of the fire.
Now, we'll take this.
Let's put it in some coals, and just
leave it there and see how well it cooks.
The cinnamon roll might be expanding
beyond the boundaries of our orange Peel.
I don't like putting things in
orange peels. It doesn't work well.
You will need to stop having this idea.
Update on the cinnamon roll,
it very quickly expanded
beyond the boundaries
set by the orange peel,
Parts of it sticking out
started burning and a lot of it
in the middle is still completely raw.
I'm not liking the look of this one.
Ah!
Taking a look at our cinnamon roll
cooked in an orange peel.
Honestly, I came across
a lot of issues with this one.
First off, the cinnamon roll quickly
began to expand and it grew to the point
where it's much larger than
the orange peel it was sitting in.
The parts that reached
over the edge of the orange peel
very quickly started to burn and the
middle is still just incredibly doughy.
This is not ready to eat.
This part over here is just
burnt to straight charcoal.
That's that's completely
inedible right there.
Scoop it out of the orange.
The bottom of our orange peel
has started to burn right through.
So that's not providing
much of a barrier there.
Let's burn bits.
We probably do have some parts
of this that are edible.
It's like charcoal and orange.
In the end, there may be a great way
to go to cinnamon roll inside of an orange
peel but I don't think it's worth it.
The method I chose just
failed in every possible way.
I would not eat this at all.
I would rather just take the dough
and wrap it around a stick
and carefully cook that over the fire.
It's a lot more likely to work.
Our next camping hack is for if you
find yourself in a situation
where you don't have quite
enough dishes to eat off of.
The idea is that you can
take aluminum foil,
mold them around something
that is dish shaped,
and then use that to eat out of.
Making this dish out of foil.
We're just wrapping around the bowl,
but one of the key elements is
that you're supposed to
take all the extra foil
sort of crumpled that and pinch it
down to be a rim
that will help reinforce
the strength of the dish.
There's one, let's try the same
thing using our propane canister.
We've now got two small
dishes made of aluminum foil
and we need to test
how well these will actually work.
Obviously, they hold their own shape.
I think it's just a matter of how
useful they are at this point.
Let's take the smaller one and fill
it up some water to see how it does.
That way we can see if it work as a cup,
maybe a small bowl if you're eating soup.
Seems to be holding up okay.
It is warping a little bit as I'm holding it,
kinda give it some support
from beneath really, but
but if you had soup,
maybe it can.
You heated that up in the fire,
and didn't have anything out of,
this could probably work for that.
I was thinking I was going to try
and put this container in the fire
to see if I could get the water to boil in it,
but I think even if I got it to boil,
there's no way I would ever be
able to get this container
back out of the fire.
At that point, the foil would be too hot
for me to grab and this is far too flimsy
of a container to try and pick
up with something like sticks.
Using our bigger container,
we're going to use this little
desert moon pie and see how well
this dish works just for eating out of.
I think the problem arises when
you want to use it as a normal plate.
This isn't exactly something
you can use utensils on.
I'm pretty sure it's just going
to cut right through the bottom.
Now, this cookie dessert that I'm
cutting up is actually extremely soft,
and I could just cut it with a spoon,
but using it with a normal fork and knife,
I think you can see that I've
managed to stab some holes
right through the bottom of this plate.
This is just aluminum foil.
It's extremely thin even with
the double layer that I made.
So, while these aren't terribly practical,
you may very well find yourself in a
situation where it's exactly what you need.
It's just something to put food
in that you can scoot back out
and eat rather than having to use
your hands or something like that.
Ten camping life hacks put to the test.
Some worked great,
some didn't work at all.
If you know any other
camping hacks or life hacks
that you want to see us put to the test,
let us know down in the comments.
Guys, that's not all,
we've got more for you to see.
That little box up at the top will
transport you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will show you what
YouTube thinks you need to be watching next,
and this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe you to our channel
so you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.